my name is Giovanni Giorgi o morado but
you can call me George oh it's Willie
started with the song I feel of where I
had a baseline which repeated over and
over and then Donna some sang on top
which is kind of romantic but put this
mechanically rhythm and recording you
can get into certain mood where the
rhythm goes on and you forget yourself a
little bit but then it cannot get too
long because then it gets before you so
it's it's a combination of the
pettishness and melodies great memories
with the station to station we're going
to record all the different sounds
during the trip on the train like the
sound of the passage of another train
in the evening we are going to assemble
all the stuff and create a landscape of
sounds and then held the guitar I add a
voice and a base and and create a song
out of it we don't know what it is we
just know that we're hopefully getting
some great sounds from the train to
create that the memory of that one-day
trip in the four-minute zone